there's no doubting what you've achieved
on a technical level these are clearly
state of the art there are just certain
design choices that were made for these
robots that we don't fully understand we
were hoping that you could shed some
light on those she can dance she can
sing she's equipped with a built-in
helium tank for inflating balloons right
at Ithaca tips
she can take song requests she can even
dispense ice cream with all due respect
those aren't the design choices we were
curious about mister after mr. Afton
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
freddy's now we're in a sister location
which means that we're not in a freddy
fazbear's pizzeria and that introduction
was interesting because we just got
introduced to two new characters we've
never heard from before or at least
that's what I'm assuming because that
definitely wasn't phone guy and the
other guy mr. Afton seems to be the
designer of at least these animatronics
now in my mind I'm wondering if this guy
designed all the animatronics but I'm
not a hundred percent sure about that
because these guys are definitely
definitely from a fundamental standpoint
different than the previous day
animatronics so honestly who knows we
don't know anything at this point so I'm
gonna stop theorizing I'm gonna stop
assuming anything about this game
because I don't know a damn thing and
we're gonna get right into the meat of
this story right now so I want to thank
Scott for giving me early access to
did you hear words there too the first
day of your exciting new career high
whether you were approached at a jump
fair read our hat and screws bolts and
hair pins or if this is the result of a
dare we welcome you I will be your
personal guide to help you get started
I'm a model five of the handyman's
robotics and unit repair system but you
can call me hand unit your new career
promises challenge intrigue and endless
janitorial opportunities please enter
your name is seen above the keypad oh
okay not be changed later so please be
careful wait is my name Mike
do I have to enter that name I mean okay
wait a minute Mike as in Mike Schmidt
because Mike Schmidt was the first guy
from the first five nights at freddys
and I'm not a hundred percent sure that
was that no no if I can hit this hey I
think I got it ma
no no oh here's our I can't read this ha
ha
it seems that you had some trouble with
the keypad oh I see what you were trying
to tie it and I will autocorrect it for
you one moment
welcome eggs benedict
I'm not Benedict Cumberbatch I'm me I'm
markiplier thanks for entering my name
Grillo Jesus what the hell is going on
here oh that's so weird
Oh what is this where am I
hello is someone gonna let me out of
here
am I actually going Wow oh cool oh
that's really cool now sky when he when
he gave me the key he said that this
game was going to be very open the
elevator
using that bright red and obvious button
Oh
let's get to work okay all right then
huh boy oh boy why is it all danger why
is it danger why why are we in the
danger I don't want to crawl down there
okay let's crawl down there allow me to
fill this somewhat frightening silence
with some light-hearted banter due to
the massive success and even more so the
unfortunate closing of Freddy fazbear's
pizza it was clear that the stage was
set no pun intended for another
contender in children's entertainment
unlike most entertainment venues our
robotic entertainers are rented out for
private parties during the day and it's
your job to get the robots back in
proper working order before the
following morning you are now in the
primary control module it's actually a
crawl space between the two fronts
showrooms now let's get started with
your daily tasks view the window to your
left oh this is the bowl or a gallery
party room and dance studio encouraging
kids to get fit and enjoy pizza let's
turn on the light and see if Belle Laura
is on stage press the blue button on the
elevated keypads to your left I'm trying
man Oh where's it looks like Bo Laura
does it feel like dancing Oh what's he
for some motivation press the red button
now to administer a controlled shock
maybe that will put the spring back in
her step why do I want Dancy pants to be
mad at me
lure the light again
I don't wanna why are you making me do
this oh it's broken oh oh now she's
dancing but Laura is feeling like her
old self again and will be ready to
perform again tomorrow
oh now view the window to your right oh
this is the fun time Auditorium where
fun time foxy encourages kids to play
and share try the light let's see what
fun time foxy is up to again I don't
know if I want to if I know anything
about angering any animatronic it's that
foxy is a big old bag of dicks and hates
me
oh geez looks like fun time foxy is
taking the day off let's motivate
funtime foxy with a controlled shock ah
nothing like a good bit of electro
motivation to get the day started
ha pedido jeez maybe it's like Futurama
and they really like this stuff let's
try another control job how about we
don't how about we don't how about we
give them a nice cupcake everyone goes
along with their day
looks like fun time foxy is in perfect
working order hey oho in front of you is
another vent shaft crawl through it to
reach the circus gallery control module
don't want it why are you making me
crawl everyone else's boss to crawl
through the vents to kill me and they're
gonna do that I have a funny feeling why
can't I look around here
oh why do I need to crawl faster motion
trigger circus galavant let me pretend
something else that's something else
I'm [ __ ] if that's me yeah okay on the
other side of the glass is Lucas baby's
auditorium
let's check the light and see what baby
is up to maybe we don't maybe I should
quit this horrible job I mean I'm
literally being talked to by an
artificial intelligence what era is this
in it's like steampunk or electro Punk
technology here point home she's not
there looks like a few of the lights are
out but we can fix that later let's
encourage baby - cheer up with a control
shock something tells me anger and baby
might be the worst decision
yeah let's try another control job let's
do that thing oh there's a lot there's a
lot of beepers and Bupers over here I'm
gonna beep and bonk my way to beep down
I can't click on your nose you're you
look like you dead balloon employee over
there that is definitely a hundred
percent balloon boy over there nice okay
let's try another control job why can't
you do this why does it have to be a
physical button that way you can place
the blame on me
[Music]
great job circus baby we knew we could
count on you that concludes your duties
for your first night on the job we don't
want you to leave overwhelmed otherwise
you might not come back please leave
using the vent behind you and we'll see
you again tomorrow well I didn't see
baby I don't see her where is she Oh
maybe maybe I'm just gonna maybe I'm
gonna forget about this and go back all
right goodbye oh man that's so weird
all right let's get Adil on out of here
[Music]
I'm home where's welcome to my dreams
another day another dramatic entry in
the lives of flan and his distressed
mistress where will they go what will
they do all of that and more happening
now
Clara I tell you the baby isn't mine and
the baby turns his bottles into powdered
milk that doesn't mean anything he
sleeps on the ceiling fan will Vlad and
his distressed mistress find common
ground tune in next time what I am I am
so unbelievably utterly confused right
now but then again this is why this is
what Scott said this game was gonna I
[Music]
don't know maybe your daddy doesn't want
you welcome back for another night of
intellectual stimulation pivotal career
choices and self-reflection on past
mistakes we're committed to creating a
unique and fulfilling work experience
one part of that commitment is ensuring
that you don't get tired of the voice
that you're hearing right now using the
keypad below please select a new
companion voice mail press 1 for female
press 2 for text only press 3 for other
options press for fun it seems that you
had some trouble with the keypad I see
what you were trying to tie
and I will autocorrect it for you oh
cool thank you for choosing angsty teen
okay no no am I gonna get an angsty teen
here are you gonna turn into an angsty
teen bruh you gonna give me some angst
you're gonna be my my online dark
applier persona
[Music]
should I be worried about that I can't
remember if that happened last time I
was here geez oh man it's so weird I can
see the reflection behind me oh boy
night 2 we're already plowing through
this game I can't wait to see how we get
through this okay
caboose key oh the elevators stopped you
know the routine
get on now or whatever you hear if you
want really can I stay here what'll
happen if I stay here hello hello hello
oh hi okay all right goodbye
here we go here we go so funny story a
dead body was found in this vent once
okay so not that funny but it's a story
oh yeah that's a great story well not a
great story but yeah it's a story
alright was it my dead body are you
reporting for the future because a
bruiser I'm gonna die here
okay let's start with your nightly
chores you should check on Valora and
make sure she's on her stage but
whatever
oh I guess but Laura has better things
to do
let's zap er yeah it should be fun okay
it's still not okay with those things in
the in the distance blinking rapidly I
have no idea what those are let's check
out funtime foxy make sure he's ready
for Showtime tomorrow wait was that like
a voice sing well we didn't even check
out Laura
i foxy in the shadows great great great
ah there seems to have been a problem
with the voice synthesizer default
settings have been restored please
proceed through the vent ahead of you to
Circus baby's auditorium
foxy a shark also I just noticed there's
a vent down by foxy an event down Bible
Laura when the hell are you gonna make
me go in those places because that's
door nice I don't want to do that I
would rather do anything with that
oh geez I'm a brave boy
I'm a brave okay so there's always oh so
this is the circus gallery vent then you
got the foxy vent then you got the bull
or event circus baby had a busy day
today
let's check the light and make sure
she's in proper working order okay Oh
seer Oh circus baby we aren't here to
play hide and seek let's encourage baby
to come out of hiding with a controlled
shock let's try another controlled shock
baby there seems to be a power
malfunction that is affecting our
ability to properly motivate baby huh
huh please stand by while I reboot the
system I don't want to Sam I will be
offline momentarily during this process
various other systems may be offline as
well such as security doors
vent locks and oxygen commencing system
restart
motion trigger injury wave end Hey hmm
fun time auditorium maintenance vent
opened Boulevard calorie maintenance
vent opened
I don't recognize you you are new I
remember this scenario however it's a
strange thing to want to do to come here
I'm curious what events would lead a
person to want to spend their nights in
a place like this
well Angley may be curiosity maybe
ignorance there is a space under the
desk someone before you crafted it into
a hiding place and it worked for him I
recommend that you hurry though you will
be safe there just try not to make eye
contact it will be over soon
they will lose interest yeah yeah I know
I'm under the desk
I mean grab here oh okay what did that
do oh that was hard to do yeah okay
I'm fully closed hi who wants to face me
in a battle to the death
I'm literally cornered right now
baby
baby
no that's a lie yeah I'm different
[Music]
are you
nope
[Music]
no I was trying I was really trying Oh
God
those horrifying I'd to fight for my
life
ah let's really pull on the son of a
[ __ ] oh geez how again oh [ __ ] this
[ __ ] so like okay so my problem was I
was pulling away too far what I needed
to do was I needed to keep my my little
mouse hand on it and like keep it there
that was good though
oh man I like this this is good
that was legitimately terrifying it was
so stress inducing
shut the [ __ ] up oh hey you still there
hi okay so you know you don't know that
you don't know oh that's so weird
that's so weird no no no no okay I just
gotta click and hold on it
there we go that's much better so like
an idiot I was under the desk just kind
of like oh oh no oh it's that bad
alright for me I'm such a fool and then
they killed me and hate my brains so
what's interesting is the voice on the
intercom
after the power shutdown was not baby
because I believe this is baby oh geez
come on oh really hard oh geez I'm
pulling this okay there we go this is
baby whispering to me because I remember
from the trailer he's watching us okay
bye who's watching you who's watching
when your guide comes back online he is
going to tell you that he was
unsuccessful that you must restart the
system manually he will then tell you to
crawl through a bull or a gallery as
fast as you can to reach the breaker
room if you follow his instructions you
will die it belong to her stage anymore
she will catch you if the power will be
restored shortly when you crawl through
Valora
gallery go slowly she cannot see you and
can only listen for your movement when
you hear her music become louder she is
growing near listening for you
wait and be still okay thank you for
your patience it seems that the power
system cannot be restarted automatically
you will need to restart the power
system manually please return to the
primary control module
okay I'm gonna do that I'm gonna do that
thing a bungee jumper go there okay here
we go going to this balloon going to see
Dancy pants we're gonna oh geez this
game okay you will now be required to
crawl through the ball or a gallery
using the vent to your left to reach the
breaker room it is recommended that you
stay low to the ground and reach the
other side as fast as possible as to not
disturb the Laura I will deactivate
myself momentarily as to not create an
auditory disturbance deactivating okay
all right so apparently if I go through
this super fast I'll die let's go
it seems you are taking a long time
please proceed as quickly and as quietly
as possible suspect
[Music]
[Music]
each freaking room
you may now interface with the breaker
control box the interface may disrupt
nearby electronics if you feel you are
in danger feel free to disconnect the
interface temporarily until it is safe
to reconnect mascot response audio
who the [ __ ] is that
[Music]
Oh God
this place restart Oh
danger level maximum everything's okay
[Music]
Oh God
oh [ __ ] I thought I thought he got
elevated he did he is elevated he is
okay Jesus
I'm never gonna I just got to hold it
right right okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you will now be required to crawl
through the bowl or a gallery using the
vent to your left to reach the breaker
room deactivating oh okay I think that's
all for this episode I made a lot of
progress but this is really cool
look I can't deny it's different it's
definitely different but it's got
elements of a lot of different things
here and I like what what's really
interesting here is I haven't explored
the entirety of the game yet there's
still another section and apparently
according to the map there's like ten
other sections out there and more vents
to core all through and like so many
things to worry about this is
legitimately amazing what has been
accomplished here and I love it it's
really good and my god I know Jesus I
didn't think it was Freddy that was
gonna get me I thought I didn't know who
was talking there like who the [ __ ] was
that and who was the mascot was that
little Bonnie on the puppet stand there
was no there's no I have no idea
oh my god this is amazing so I'm gonna
get more videos of this out as soon as I
can but we made good progress here it's
just so fascinating it's so fascinating
what's going on here I want to know so
much more about it so we will find it
out very soon thank you again everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you think of this down in the comments
below and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]